after roughly 18 viewings and getting
Bohemian Rhapsody stuck in my head I'm
here to help break down seven questions
we at ET have after watching the insane
Suicide Squad trailer first of all who
is the villain in the movie I mean
besides the obvious for bad guys it's
what we do we're inclined to think
Enchantress considering she's off doing
her own thing and what is she up to at
the White House let's do something fun
and sorry guys but it's called Suicide
Squad orrow reason we're taking bets
who's gonna die first you're going
somewhere very bad do something they'll
get killed oh hey Skye Eastwood um who
are you in this movie the internet has
been trying to crack this code but it's
entirely possible he's just a dashingly
handsome man we're meeting for the very
first time I'm kidding that's than what
they really said there's been a divided
on this but I'm loving this version of
Harley Quinn what up girl still we've
got to wonder how far her accent will go
and will she call her man Mista J mr.
Jai speaking of Joker are we actually
gonna love jared leto's version after
all we were pretty weary but he's gone
full cartoon in this trailer and we're
kind of all about it I can't wait to
show you my toys the final and most
important question of all drumroll
please
what is Jai Courtney drinking is it a
soda a beer either way totally relatable
you